Are you able to order ultrasounds or similar tests? No, we're not a prescribing clinic,
not a licensed practitioner. I can't order tests that require those types of licenses.
That's beyond our scope of practice. I'm pretty sure that even a licensed
chiropractor in your area could probably order an ultrasound. It depends on your area,
that's your in as well. I know if you're in, let's say, the Twin Cities area,
your big metropolitan area, ultrasounds can be had at local radiology clinics,
and those could be ordered by any licensed practitioner in the state, including a chiropractic
license. There's no chiropractic licensures in both states, but
and there are some states you could actually just get an ultrasound without having a doctor's
order at all. It just depends on the clinic. I would search ultrasounds in your area. I don't
know whoever asked this question would area there and live it in and how big the betropolis is.